In this segment, we are working three great plyometric exercises...
...to help volleyball players build the leg strength needed to jump higher.
High knee skips are a challenging exercise, activating your hip flexors...
...as well as improving leg strength, coordination and endurance.
Frog hops are a great exercise for developing explosive jumping power,...
...working the quads and hamstrings.
Just think for a second about the body size of a frog...
...and then look at the height and distance of their jumps.
Skater drills are great for working explosive power, balance and body control.
This drill can be done at a slower pace, working strength and balance,...
...or at maximum effort, spending as little time as possible on the ground,...
...working on explosive jumping power.